I am jeon reply of the viewing a talk
called three weird tips for
high-performance satellite applications
and let's get going funny talking over
twist time I mean Gian really know I'm
committer and remember on the druid
project it's a data project that started
about five six years ago build for it's
really built to power I don't like
complications and this talk is going to
be partially about the techniques we
used in droid to make them possible and
techniques you can use with druid and
also about what work we're doing with
that and apply which is company I
started a couple years ago that that's
all built around price Tara how many
folks if you have heard of you are using
through it well how many of have any of
those answered users alright it will
awesome I love you guys Mabel makes you
to self-awareness so agenda first
Internet ruin and I want to talk about
the virtues three virtues of three weird
tips you know that we're remedy
foresight and flexibility so first off
what is turned rude is an open source I
performance column-oriented distributed
datastore it's a mouthful what does that
mean so we can unpack it a bit high
performance means were shooting for low
quarry latency and high ingest rates so
that's a key part of the DNA of our
project column-oriented that's possible
scan rates confrontation is the
technology you use when you want to do
an analytic database it's common amongst
all idolized databases distributed we're
just we're typically deployed in
clusters the normal drink cluster size
is tens to hundreds of nodes the biggest
clusters are pushing a thousand pounds
and then data store it stores a copy of
your data that doesn't quarry data
somewhere else that loads copper data
into itself in the queries in and what
problem are we trying to solve so the
problem we're trying to solve are we're
trying to make analytic applications and
these are a screenshot of the island
application
we may can imply it's an app built on
top of urine and the idea with Madeleine
complication is you want to be able to
slice his diet supply through your data
and what they'll explore your data build
dashboards and you also want to be able
to see what's going on behind the
dashboard so you know have a dashboard
they can explore and drill into it and
ideas to figure out what's happening
bill operational awareness diagnose
problems and sort of you know to have a
dialogue with your data and to do that I
have speakers are important a lot of
people are using during for this kind of
thing
so this is on people that are from the
direct our time page you can see a lot
of big names there some of these were
some of the earliest adopters of pure
including Yahoo and Netflix and quote
from Yahoo they more of one of the
earliest or inductors the performance is
great some of the tables that we have
internally enjoyed have billions and
billions of events in them and we're
scanning them in under a second so
that's the kind of thing that we're
shooting for with Jordan so let's talk
about the first purchase revenue so
revenue is about compression so one of
the one of the things we do enjoy to
kick the performance is we compress your
data and compress any text so if this is
part of the talk I'm going to go into
how we compressed a material you can see
here that we've got a we've got a sample
dataset
Wikipedia edits so this is a timestamp
of an edit page the edited language
together to England's Wikipedia page is
Justin Bieber ketchup and then some
information about user doing that it so
they came from San Francisco became
Calgary etc they added and deleted some
number of words so the way that we're
going to store this like I said we're
going to store it or at a store in
columnar
so when I see a columnar and we're going
to store it every column dependently
which is important because there's
there's two ways of storing data the
penis is stored row oriented you can
sort a column where it usually systems
designed for transactions or updates
that kind of thing will store a data row
base they'll store all the other for the
same road
there's even updated easily systems
assigned to analytics like curative
usually stored data in columns and the
reason for that is because your data
might have dozens of columns and for a
typical analytical quarry you're not
going to quarry in every column it's
going to be something like I want the
top ten page and it's my number of bits
that's two columns page and count and
you don't want to worry about loading
data for the other forty columns and so
if I owned by storing data separately we
only load data for the columns we need
and really that's why this is the virtue
of revenues it's about only only using
exactly the name of ebony dance for you
so for the page column we're going to
store a array of our first story
dictionary so we're gonna take those two
values two unique values Justin Bieber
and Kesha we are going to ecologist zero
zero and catch a one so they're integers
and then we're going to store each
column has an integer array so the page
or column is going to be an array of 0 0
0 1 1 1 and the language column is going
to be an array of all zeros because it's
just one value and then on top of that
we do compression so the dictionary
encoding is a form of compression in
addition we do fit packing and so for
example these these dictionary and these
are integers and if there's a 32 bits
we're not actually to store them at 32
bits here there's only two values were
going to store them one day so we'll
store them in whatever number of bits is
necessary and then in the future we're
actually currently working in the germ
unity on other kinds of compression so
there's a frame of reference compression
that we're looking at rather than pakodi
which were looking at berlin's encoding
being great for situations where you
have very sparse column you know they
have mostly nulls and then a value
mostly knows and then a value you don't
want to store of what you don't want
store a few bits or every know you
wanted to store you want to say like I
have 100 novels in that day so there's a
lot of a lot of cool ways to compress a
lot of points of compress columns
different kinds of compression to work
different for different kinds of columns
so
better for others and others and one of
the things we're looking at in the
German world is having an adaptive
compression for another person based on
your data so looking at the data and
having some say like you may accelerate
do I want to optimize for speed or not
optimized for size and haven't think of
frankly and then finally LZ for optional
and also optionally into an LZ for
compression on top of this the reason
you might want to do that is because you
really want optimize for space because
what impacting and arlenian people or do
they look at slightly different aspects
of the data than it was before it does
so it can be beneficial to find them
it's not always and so that's why it is
it optional and ok what else do we do so
that's how we need to store your data we
started in this column or compressed
format we also index it so the this is
also part of the virtue of gravity it's
we don't want to even load we split
things up into columns so that's a
little cop to need now we use indexes
they don't have to load rows that we
don't need so we don't want to load
let's save a filter on the page column
we don't want to read the entire page
columns to a filter who I have an index
on page so we've got an index in that
every column in this case the index for
the page column is it look like Justin
Bieber goes to row 0 1 & 2 the first
three rows caption goes to 3 4 & 5
she's in the second 3 rows and those
monthly were sent as bit vectors where
the is 0 if the values in the column in
the bit is 1 the value goes to zero if
not the probably what if it is in the
column so then we can at query time we
can look up the values and then we can
use those bit vectors to resolve which
rosy skin and other columns so if you're
saying I want to know the top cities
they're an editing Tuscany verbal we can
do there because they're gonna load the
index for the page column look at the
value for Justin Bieber get a list of
rows out and look at those rows of the
city column so we're really minimizing
the amount of minimize the amount of
data we need to read to that query and
those bitmaps are nice because they can
be combined across columns we can do if
you have an and filter or filter for
home page will such a fever and City
equal San Francisco
we can get the map from the page column
from the city column and combine them
together so it's nice for boolean
filters across columns as well we also
use compression for this there's two
kinds of depression we use what is
called roaring and one is called concise
I guess talked about those is a little
bit us go for the top of it there
they're both good in different
situations roaring is better in most
situations we might come to fall if I
conferred to as a virtue of foresight
then you move into the talk yesterday it
was called lazy be smart and fast so
that was about a part of that was about
doing summarizations of data and say you
know I would improve on some sets of
dimensions and I'm gonna query the query
in the summarization that gives me the
best performance if I'm only if I have a
summarization that hits it's you follow
them support that one that's what this
is about so we call it roll up and
ruined it's a feature that we support
materials actually built in and the idea
is it's a projection of a table also
public OLAP cube and it can provide a
serious reduction in row count so let me
show you how that works so an example
here against the data set of car sales
so cars of sale sold in a certain time a
certain make model year a sale price TLT
so how can we apply and roll up to
reduce the size of the data set
all we can did we can do something like
this so we took this data set that was
originally seven rows and made it four
rows it's a pretty substantial reduction
in row size almost 2 X means queries are
going to be almost 2x faster just great
what did we do what we did was we split
the columns in two times one is called
dimensions or one column so the
dimensions the white ones
colors a little bit tough to see but the
first four time make model year
those are fields we want to group
and filter on and the manager feel to
want to a grenade so this is built
around aggregations so we don't
necessarily we don't have the raw data
for the measured so we have the ability
to aggregate rooms so we can now count
Bruce we can see the 3d Rose three
source roads went for that first
activated room we have some the sale
price so we can compute the sum sale
price now we can compute the sum of
sales fee and the minimums healthy out
of this roll-up we can't compute the max
sales team because we haven't we haven't
stored that measure in the role of table
in the summarization people so it's the
value of foresight because you have to
have a little bit of an idea of what
kinds of course you're going to want to
do you have to know I'm gonna want to
filtering the group of these attributes
I'm gonna want to do these kinds of
aggregations so it's a little bit of
understanding of what kinds of words
you're gonna want to do you can roll up
on those dimensions and those measures
and a lot of cases get a substantial
additional row account like I was saying
earlier it could be to be you know two
to 100 X final one flexibility so the
virtual flexibility is about
approximation if you don't median exact
answers why about is that answers
especially if you're trying to do an
exploratory workflow like I was saying
earlier you're trying to interact with
their data have interactive dashboard
data load applications a lot of times
fast response time is more important
than having the exact answer especially
the era can be bound into something like
you know two or three percent so in drew
and we support a lot of approximate a
lot of approximate algorithms because
we're build for this kind of thing so we
support approximate ranking so that was
you know top page mine is approximate
distant Calvin approximate distinct kept
with set operations like intersection
and zombie and also approximate
histograms and quantiles
the approximations all have in common
that their memory is bounded or slow
growing so they're not going to use a
ton of memory to the high power now the
input and also be error is sometimes
done so another example here hyper logon
let me call our familiar with some use
well it's a really popular algorithm for
distinct counting around a little while
I think there's a whole family of
algorithms called sketches that are
algorithms that use these really neat
and memory structures to approximate
answers to various questions if you got
time out to the top you know and if you
get home like look up step is online
they're really awesome Hydra logs more
than granddaddy's the sketches if it's
one of them it's been around for a while
it's used for travel statements based on
the independence of hash functions so
this is a sort of flavor house I just
work in general think about hashing a
bunch of values let's say I want to do a
distinct count of billions of values and
how many of that we take those billions
of values I'm gonna hash them all with
the strong platforms or the decent hash
function does every super strong Biddy
said perforce okay assuming the house
function is decent and if different bits
positions are independent of each other
which is what you want from a good hash
function 50% of the values will start
with one 25% start with zero line 12.5%
start with 0 0 1 and so on
and what we can notice there is that
let's say that we catch things let's say
we have a sketch that just keeps track
of the maximum number of zeros we've
seen the beginning of hash values so we
have stability of things and after after
a billion things they expect to see
whatever number of zeros the middle hash
value so let's say we've hashed a bunch
of things we don't know what they are we
don't know how many and we see the most
zeros you never seen in a row is 4 so we
see 0 0 0 and then 1 and that was the
most here was never seen to beginning
we're gonna guess there without 32
things because we would have expected to
see that whoever said to see that one
time if there were 32 things that's old
guests were there any things obviously
this is not super accurate it can only
get powers of 2 you can think of a lot
of cases this can be super wrong so we
do instead that's the general idea that
the refinement to that is
a bunch of times and a bunch of buckets
so we actually have a thousand different
buckets we're doing this 1,000 different
times there's a in this example and we
see only 64 buckets as a function or so
there's a parameter called K this number
of bits you can use for marketing the
first K that's let's say UK is six the
first six beds is determined what bucket
number news and the next bits are what
we're going to look at the leading zero
distribution so we do a hash we've
hashed this value this is going to go in
bucket number one because if you know
the first six bits the ones on the first
pocket or second market against the
first one in those zeros and then we're
going to store one there because there
is one leading zero and so we do this in
a bunch of buckets and then we apply
some sweet math that's in the hyperbolic
neighbor and out pops a cardinality
estimation that you can actually prove
has a bounded air depending on the K
value holding on this is the K value you
use to you can use control whenever you
want and then the total size of the hash
in particular the amounts over after the
K value controls the maximum number of
things you could possibly count because
of course here you know if if you had a
trillion things in there you wouldn't
have enough you wouldn't have no CFO you
can only count them two to the number of
zeros you have left over so that second
part controls your max and then the the
first part controls your resolution and
okay so those are the three virtues we
got brevity remedy compression foresight
roll ups and flexibility approximate
algorithms I wanted to end by saying you
can try this at home
druid is open source the company I work
for implies the distribution of jury can
get on our website we are available both
places the apply solution additionally
on top of jury to include applications
those screenshots I was showing earlier
I said Jorun is used for powering
analytic applications and so we drive it
out of the box or you can write your own
on the drip platform you can also
contribute it's open source with a fiber
community as you can see if there are
none of the jury
github we've got 212 contributors 405
releases but we'll start it where I'm
getting up so you can come on over there
and showing the development we've also
recently begun migrating to be Apache
Incubator
so that means Apache Tribe is coming
soon which is really exciting for us and
finally had applied we are hiring for
which everything both the app and for
tourism pitch them to ad placement our
management - the first question is that
my privileges track hood one of you
thought about using Z standard along
with lz4 and that under the family like
optional compression algorithms that may
be applicable so yeah we have thought
about it in the mode of not doing it
partially because we are moving to a
world where LZ fourth less necessary the
main reason anything else before now so
I was saying before it's good because
the so you know hourly or length
encoding and for offset reference and
packing those are all things that are
specific to integers and design
compressing integer array LZ for a
general purpose and sometimes I was
before can find and 280 that the other
compressors didn't this but what we're
hoping is that with this adapted I
stopped talking about there's a lot is a
really amazing literature on integer
specific integer array specific
compressions
our hope is that was adaptive pressure
conscious out and is paired with the
blending things are bad amazing
literature that general-purpose
compressors are just gonna be waste of
time
what's the easiest way to don't pop
compliance into it
these going to do that is to we have a
parking extension in Druid it's a
contributing country extensions you can
download it up the maven central I think
and it works without the deplored so
injure it we have three main ways to
data and you can blow it using a nuke
job you can load directly in a batch
mode from some file system lengths or
some object store like s3 or you can
load directly from Kafka and so for
archive files you've probably run it I
mean it's like they probably didn't to
do is usually where most parking I was
nervous to you dad so you want to use
the new player function ality there I
guess maybe just a question around these
cases like so what inspired you to go
and build room that is supposed to be
using a lot of the solutions that were
already available just I guess what I'm
trying to get as like if I'm thinking
about incorporating for my case tackling
what are leading indicators that it
might be the red technology versus just
another piece of infrastructure that I
now have to care that's a great question
we have actually hold on to talk about
that but the short version is that what
we were looking for with something back
to the real time data something that
didn't require pre-computation of
aggregates so you know because something
that worked with high dimensionality and
high cardinality and what we were
finding that it was we didn't find the
account there that hit all those buttons
and the the 61 look important for the
toilet report every singer that was
something that could be online 24/7 so
the we we major because we couldn't find
anything that that hit all bad that that
was sort of able to be elastically
scaled up and down and not take downtime
updated without making downtime and load
data in real time and I think that you
know if what I see what I see today with
all the other solutions that are out
there is that there's the situations
that it turn the situation warrants
which is really
it's something that you're trying to
don't add a lock application you're
getting data maybe in real time in from
the Duke and you have a lot of you have
a high dimensionality data type are now
in the data and here at your if you're
facing a problem it's like oh my god I
have you know I have some dimension are
asking column that's got millions of
values from trying to bring me over in
China I don't know what did I do I'm not
sure how to handle this
there's not a lot of tools to handle
that a lot of the relative proximation
stuff like that but that's that's the
the area of work that's done you
mentioned that there are people running
thousands no closer could you but this
is a big thing but it is sort of brief
answer the question of where does do it
fall in the camp or back out look at the
arises in terms of just react systems
and availability and consistency yeah
availability for reads and doesn't see
for writes so we chose so in truancy we
have an interesting architecture where
the reading and writing subsystems are
very separated for each other so we call
it the reading system we call the
historical notes and the writing
subsystem we called indexing notes and
so is that on the it is that any data
that is that was written more than about
an hour ago is going to be off
historical site and we really prioritize
availability there and any data on the
real time side we prioritize consistency
in Ludington Kafka
so what you know for example in order to
paint consistency you can say may be
unavailable for a little while or
something like that or maybe we made
blocked the main block and not accept
rights for a little bit
so as this design friend it's super high
availability the right side we always
accept right even if it can't handle
them it might throw some way if we are
not able to accept right suppose talking
something for a bit and kind of let the
system flush out if the index node
crashes then we don't restore our
offsets along with the different
segments that we crashes we backed up
and read
Tosca exactly what's so we got kind of
an interesting space there because
because we split architecture but we did
that because we're trying to both
provide good good operational properties
around high uptime for building upon and
also reasonable guarantees around you
want to make sure that the data that you
haven't drew it matches what is in your
source system like a duper cockpit we
will try to make that happen
you